bonsoir
alors mon nom était dehors tetro est
effectivement métier c'est de conseiller
le pouvoir et l'argent
ces deux conseillers les puissants ceux
qui nous gouvernent ou ceux qui ont
vocation à nous gouverner
ceux qui ont de grandes fortunes ceux
qui ont vocation à en construire et en
même temps alors ce n'est pas un brevet
de sainteté ou d'intelligence et en même
temps je suis catholique croyant mon
dieu c'est c'est celui du sermon sur la
montagne c'est celui qui au lieu de
devenir un hub hermach ou une machine
s'est fait homme et c'est l'essai cloué
sur une croix pour mourir comme un rat
mort mon dieu c'est celui du lavement
des pieds c'est celui qui dit qu'il est
bien plus facile à un chameau de passer
par le chas d'une aiguille qu'à un riche
de rentrer dans le grand royaume des
cieux
donc autant vous dire que pour exercer
mon métier good luck
comment est ce que j'essayais de
réconcilier ce paradoxe où ces deux
termes
ce en quoi je crois et est ce que je
fais dans ma vie j'ai fait d'une façon
très concrète hier comme analyste
financier aujourd'hui comme comme
conseiller de dirigeants c'est que dès
que le monde de l'argent ou du pouvoir
politique se met à totalement se
déconnecter par rapport au monde des
êtres humains
je dis attention je dis stop
alors ceux qui m'ont suivie dans les
marchés savent que effectivement les
j'ai eu trois moments où
j'ai annoncé des crises la bulle
internet en mars 2000 prenez vos profits
avant un éventuel licra qu un épisode
sur le vivent indique jean-marie messier
qui était la plus grande entreprise de
médias du monde et qui passait juste à
côté de l'association de paiement et
puis la crise de 2008 que j'avais vu en
2006 j'avais fait un témoignage à la
commission des finances du sénat
maintenant que cette orgie de dette ne
pouvait pas durer
alors aujourd'hui je fais une prédiction
opa la nouvelle crise financière
évidemment elle vient elle vient cc il y
en a à peu près tous les 8 10 ans
aujourd'hui elle vient elle sera un peu
compliqué on a créé neuf mille milliards
de dollars à partir de rien sont les
banques centrales comme injecter des
liquidités
elle viendra probablement aussi des
robots puisque vous savez qu'aujourd'hui
80% des ordres de bourse sont faits par
des algorithmes
c'est à dire nous avons sorti les êtres
humains de l'équation de quelque chose
quand même important
là où nous allons notre épargne notre
richesse
elle viendra probablement des états unis
pays d'où je reviens ou monsieur trump
vient d'exonérer de des droits de
succession de l'impôt sur les
successions les 0,2 pour cent des
américains les plus riches et en même
temps taxant davantage les étudiants
vous avez aujourd'hui 44 millions
d'étudiants américains qui porte une
dette qui ne rembourseront jamais une
dette de 1500 milliards de dollars cela
fait plus de trente mille dollars par
par étudiant good luck pour ceux qui
n'ont pas les parents qui peuvent suivre
derrière
non je vous parlais d'une crise bien
plus bien plus sérieuse cette crise je
vais emprunter les mots du pape françois
qui dit que nos cultures nos économies
nos sociétés ou plutôt nous nous avons
la culture du déchet et du déchet humain
voilà ce qu'il dit aujourd'hui tout
entre dans le jeu de la compétitivité de
la loi du plus fort ou le puissant
mangent le plus faible
on considère l'être humain en lui-même
comme un bien de consommation qu'on peut
utiliser ensuite jetés il s'agit plus
simplement du phénomène de
l'exploitation et de l'oppression mais
de quelque chose de nouveau
les exclus ne sont pas des exploités
mais des déchets des restes
ce qui devient un peu sérieux c'est que
nous sommes pris à jouer ce jeu là et
nous le jouons pleinement
malheur aux faibles malheur faible dans
nos entreprises dans la société dans nos
économies
il n'y a plus de place pour eux hier il
est venu une place pour celui qui
faisait les choses moins bien
aujourd'hui non ce n'est plus possible
et vous le savez cela est un thème
récurrent de notre soirée
nous assistons au grand remplacement au
pas le grand emplacement de
l'intellectuel d'extrême droite renaud
camus qui derrière ses murailles de son
château du 14ème siècle craint que la
race blanche soit remplacé par le reste
du monde
non quelque chose de bien plus
immédiat bien plus dangereux le grand
remplacement de l'homme de l'être humain
par la machine nous y prêtons le flanc
nous le préparons ce remplacement
pourquoi parce que nous jouons en jeu
parce que nous commençons à nous penser
comme des machines à des machines avec
uniquement des capacités qui va falloir
booster pour survivre faire survivre nos
enfants produire produire mieux et
laisser derrière nous loin derrière ceux
qui n'en peuvent plus ceux qui n'auront
pas les moyens de la compétition nous le
préparons ce grand remplacement en
acceptant la marchandisation de nos
corps et de nos données aujourd'hui je
peux je vais pas être grossier mais la
réalité de notre monde et celle là si
vous voulez si vous voulez générer de la
vie les ventres à louer en inde mais ça
se rapprochera nous ces quelques
centaines de dollars
le sperme à la european space banques
cela dépend de la qualité du donneur et
aussi de sa nationalité
si vous voulez un anonyme c'est 300
dollars si vous voulez un américain avec
tout ce qu'il faut c'est 640 $ des
livres ou les autres les nouveaux coups
lise du 21e siècle louent leurs bras
leurs jambes pour 5 5 euros à peu près
de l'heure pour vous apporter votre
votre votre repas ce soir non seulement
s dans ce monde là que vous voulez vivre
vous êtes nous sommes en train de le
construire
alors face à cela il ya deux
possibilités
il y en a une c'est celle des
transhumanistes il y en a deux célèbres
récurrence belle aux états unis d'autres
qui aspirent à le devenir en france le
leur
leur parole est très simple c'est
puisque les machines arrivent devenus
des machines ne nous laissons pas
dépasser par les par les algorithmes en
gt il est un peu avec le présent d'une
compagnie d'assurances qui m'expliquait
tu comprends edwards s'est compliqué les
algorithmes j'en ai aujourd'hui qui peut
remplacer toute ma division de gestion
de
des risques et des dommages ces 4000
personnes je vais faire partir d'abord
ceux qui vont à la retraite ou en
préretraite mais un moment faudra
accélérer le rythme et bien sûr tu vas
tu vas créer des jobs en face des jobs
de big data oui oui une centaine de
pieds de jeudi il vaut mieux dans le
monde qui vient vaudrait-il mieux dans
le monde qui vient
avoir des pistes jeudi pour survivre
alors bien sûr il y en ait qui vont
jouer le jeu qui vont y aller qui vont
se greffer pardon pour qu'ils vont se
greffer des nanopuces dans leur cerveau
ça existe déjà et c'est formidable un
grand blessé qui est un accident de moto
il ya pas très longtemps n'arrivais plus
à bouger les bras les jambes en lui
greffant des nanopuces au bon endroit
eh bien on leur donnait son autonomie
les nanos puces pour réparer les vivants
oui les nanopuces pour booster son
intelligence être plus intelligent que
la machine et puis booster quoi d'autre
sa capacité plus compétitif
sa capacité à tuer tuer symboliquement
un concurrent ou tuer pour de vrai un
adversaire sa capacité à booster sa
libido formidable ouais il y en a
quelques-uns quelques-unes qui verrait
ou du calme c'est ça que nous allons
alors les transhumanistes allons-y
allons-y toute façon on n'a pas le choix
sinon les machines nous dépasserons je
crois je suis heureux parce que les
transhumanistes à chacune de leurs
déclarations sont des illustrations
vivante c'est ses apôtres de
l'intelligence artificielle son
illustration vivante de la bêtise
humaine
pourquoi parce que si nous commençons
nous greffer d'appareils en toutes
sortes mais nous resterons toujours des
brouillons des brouillons un peu lent
des draft
et si vraiment nous engageons dans cette
compétition non seulement ma l'euro
faible mais malheur à ceux qui n'auront
pas la technologie qui permettra de tuer
l'autre plus vite
donc ça sera une course à quoi une
accélération de la course à l'argent à
la puissance s dans ce monde là que vous
vivre et en plus quel calcul imbéciles
imbéciles
pourquoi parce que une machine des jours
a toujours nos intentions des jours à
puisque nous allons parier tout sur
notre intelligence et nos capacités sur
la poursuite de nos intérêts elle va
lire dans notre jeu elle nous des jours
à elle nous devancera et nous brisera
moi je vous propose une autre voie non
seulement pour eux pour ce qu'elle est
mais pour terrasser les machines les
battre bien sûr nous allons avoir des
des accessoires voiliers qui vont nous
aider mais devenir des machines pour
essayer de les battre non nous ont été
rasées en redevenant des êtres humains
que nous sommes en train de ne plus
devenir
à force de jouer le jeu des machines ça
passe par où ça passe par trois choses
que nous avons dans le jeu deux de nos
vies la compétition mondiale que nous
avons un peu laissé de côté ces trois
choses ça s'appelle l'esprit l'amour de
la vulnérabilité et la gratuité
je commence par l'esprit savez l'esprit
c'est les transhumanistes n'ont pas lu
cyrano mais d'esprit au le plus
lamentable des êtres vous n'êtes jamais
un atom et de lettres vous n'avez que
les trois qui forment le mot sow
l'esprit c'est d'abord ça c'est l'humour
les transhumanistes ont si peu d'humour
c'est normal l'humour c'est la même
racine que humus être un petit peu
humble umih humus humilité avoir les
pieds sur terre
connaître ses limites l'humour humus
humilité humains l'esprit qu'est ce que
c'est c'est quelque chose de bien
supérieur à l'intelligence l'intelligent
ce n'est qu'une faculté au sens littéral
du terme
c'est une faculté le faculté de
comprendre nous faculté de saisir une
faculté de décider une faculté
mais ce n'est que cela intel des grès
l'esprit
spir arrêt on l'attend l'esprit c'est le
souffle
c'est ce qui vient avant nous sommes
animés pas par une intelligence
nous sommes animés quand une rencontre
se fait quand quand nous décidons
quelque chose n'est pas uniquement dieu
merci la poursuite de nos intérêts nous
sommes animés de quelque chose qui nous
précèdent quelque chose qui nous qui
nous inspire quelque chose qui nous
permet de respirer c'est pas
l'intelligence c'est autre chose
l'esprit d'abord accepter qu'il y ait
quelque chose avant une faculté de faire
ensuite aimez votre vulnérabilité
elle vous faire un sondage quelqu'un
dans cette dans cette salle quelqu'un a
déjà voulu aimer une personne
invulnérable or ce que j'aime en toi
c'est ton à vulnérabilité tu les
intouchables
je ne peux pas te rendre vulnérable je
ne peux pas de blesser je ne peux pas
atteindre
mais non enfin vous imaginez mozart van
gogh malraux aurait-il pu produire le
moindre dessin le moindre son la moindre
ligne d'écriture s'il n'avait pas eu
conscience de leur finitude
est ce qu'on peut dire à quelqu un je
t'aime
si on se dit qu'on a tout le temps pour
cela si on finit son se dit ben voila
mon projet c'est de finir dans la
solitude de ma machine de mes pilules de
demont être augmentée qui va dominer les
autres regardent comme je suis un
vulnérables vient goodlock aimez votre
vulnérabilité
c'est ce qui nous si ce qui la machine
n'est pas vulnérable
c'est ce qui va la tuer enfin la
gratuité
gratuite et oui la gratuité savez le les
machines vont tout prévoir de nos gestes
tout prévoir avec les big data dont j'ai
compris qu'il fallait absolument les
données tout de suite et même peut-être
faire de l'argent avec elles vont tout
prévoir tout anticipé de vos intentions
mais elle ne prévoir on jamais
ce qui fait que vous allez aller contre
vos intérêts si fait que vous allez vous
mettre en risque pas pour vous votre
carrière
mais pour quelqu'un d'autre ce qui fait
que vous allez décider de dire à
quelqu'un je t'aime et lui confier votre
vie ce qui fait que vous allez préférer
mourir vous pour que vive la personne
que vous aimez celles et ceux qui aiment
dans cette salle celles et ceux qui ont
la chance d'avoir des enfants savent
très bien ce que je veux dire
la gratuité c'est le bug absolue pour
les machines si ce qui va les faire
disjoncter
je vais un peu plus loin je ne crois pas
beaucoup à l'as ne vous y fiez pas le
combat contre les machines va exister va
être violent va être rude
regardez ce qui se construit autour des
robots tueurs
je ne crois pas à la solidarité des
machines entre elles je croise à la
fraternité humaine la fraternité humaine
c'est celle qui va faire que nous allons
les battre
qui va faire que nous allons mettre en
réseau nous protéger parce que nous
avons quelque chose de bien plus
précieux qu'elle bien plus précieux
qu'une intelligence qu'une capacité
c'est notre esprit notre vulnérabilité
et notre gratuité qui notre capacité à
dire je t'aime sans rien attendre
merci
[Applaudissements]